my name is Quran Dodi I'm part of the
team with continued of analytics I've
been with them for about nine months now
so I'm still relatively fresh to the
scene but I've got a short presentation
rapid exploration and visualization of
large data sets I'm going to give this
short and sweet so I'm just going to hit
three topics current state of the python
visualization ecosystem I'm going to
give a few thoughts on how to build up
visualization and then we're going to
look at the NYC tax gap data set so
these are three people that I believe
all of you should be intimately familiar
with and if you're not then you will be
after this talk the first person is dr.
two key John two key he literally wrote
on an exploratory data analysis back in
1977 at that point in time there was a
lot of emphasis on fiscal analysis as
verification so you would you apply a
model to a data set in order to see how
well I'll fit the data set but there
wasn't really an idea of you know just
load up the data set and take a look at
it that kind of introduction to a data
set without you know a model already in
mind with your approach so it's not a
it's not super interesting age but he
lay the groundwork for a lot of later
fact that uh these new technology you
know which enable know what not is we
really have to thank dr. he at least for
giving us the groundwork second person
is dr. Leland Wilkinson he wrote the
grammar of graphics how many of you are
familiar with ggplot special of hands
okay good so you understand that such
bram graphics it basically separates
your description of the data from the
way that you visualize having a you know
a scatterplot you just have x and y
coordinates you have novel graphical
techniques where you can combine reshape
ash of different graphical forms in
order to create novel prep third then
dr. Hadley Wickham he is the author of
ggplot2 and I recommend his thesis which
is called practical tools for exploring
and models yeah it's a written 30 pages
but it actually goes through start to
finish how you would explore a data set
of course all the code is in are so in
so nowadays we have matplotlib plot and
bouquet those are more or less than
three mainstays for stitches to
visualization in the Python ecosystem
matplotlib just hit version 1.4 a few
weeks ago and they've really overhauled
some of the some of the basics for style
sheets so now you won't have like the
ugly jet color map is the default you
have a few more options in fact they've
got one style which is called ggplot you
know to try and emulate some of the
ggplot styles however i would highly
recommend using seaborne if you ever get
the chance seabourn has a couple of
sorry not even a couple c1 has an
impressive array of statistical
functions which take your data generally
as a data frame you can provide column
names for a regression plot or a hex bin
I'll show a few of those later in the
talk and it definitely needs to be part
of your workflow if you're planning to
do high scale statistical visualization
ggplot is actually being actively ported
over by the guys over at Y hat so if you
are coming from the our world and you
still feel more familiar with that they
actually use more or less the exact same
syntax
and then they make that quick but it
does provide a nice familiar interface
to the project that I've been working on
in fact in tomorrow by a ryan van de ven
who is right now the current lead
authors
it's a low 7 release coming up within
the next couple of weeks so should
definitely come take a look at that so
from the grammar graphics now in the
21st century what 2014 now we are
starting to evolve a poetry of graphics
you've probably in more more hopefully
scientific tops or lecturers incorporate
the ipython notebook and more the papers
that are using matplotlib and Seaborn to
create their statistical graphics will
be you know creating novel plots these
aren't just the the tried and true
scatter plots box plots these are
actually mashing up new and unique
graphics so that's applying both to the
data the way that you demonstrate the
data and as well as the models I mean
now that we're talking about machine
learning you know it's really ramped up
in the past five years especially in
Python with scikit-learn we have that a
entire tutorial this morning you can see
how these models then have to be
represented in a visual manner as well
and you're the problem is there's no
good way there's no right way yet what
we're quickly understanding is that the
proper way to show the data really
depends on the data itself really
depends on the models itself we also
have novel interactions because we are
ending the age of the browser ipython
notebook makes us explicitly clear
because now a lot of analysis is done in
a notebook right you can start at the
top you can keep executing cells until
you decide to change something so some
things that come naturally with you know
d3 style interactions are panning
zooming clicking hovering these are
things which are very valuable if you
can figure out how to hook it into your
code or a hook it into your data but
they're not there aren't very many good
Python libraries out there that do that
yet that's actually a really hard
problem to solve their they had the MPL
d3 wrapper which Jake van Kleiss wrote
to try and convert matplotlib figures
into g3 graphics right so you can play
cover and whatnot interact but each
brushing I think is actually one of the
most interesting techniques coming up
because link brushing kind of sorry link
brushing can connect
ah splotze is anybody how many people
here are familiar with link brushing
okay just a few yeah you'll definitely
want to see that in a tomorrow spoke a
talk so this is the data visualization
catalog this is the first page there are
two more I I'm throwing this up here
just so you can see the entire ecosystem
of plots that you can create to try and
represent your data right you've got arc
diagrams you've got different categories
that link to one another you've got your
regular histogram flow maps especially
important for a geographical movement or
modeling one of my favorite is the
chloroplast map I'm sure you guys use
that a lot it's also known as the heat
map this is a harder one to plug into
because it requires a geographical basis
but there are some Python libraries that
are out bouquet is also trying to hit
that same problem pie charts population
pyramids Sankey diagrams Venn diagrams I
mean basically every statistical
analysis that you can possibly think of
there it there should be a visualization
to accompany it because that
visualization makes that statistical
statistical view of the clear Oh
I'm gonna and I know that's a somewhat
strange statement to make for
exploratory data analysis you're
literally trying to look at your data
you're trying to reshape it or pipe it
into a graphical outline which gives you
a better intuition for what your data
looks like all right how many of you
have you know fired up an eye Python
notebook and decided you're going to
start scikit-learn machine learning
algorithm and you already know which one
to use in which parameters that never
happens right you have to take a look at
your data first so that's the whole
point exploratory data analysis so I've
got a cool it's got a short notebook
here which is going to be using the new
york city taxi cab data set as its basis
if you're not familiar with that the new
york city released and i think may march
of this year QA for all of the taxi
trips that were taken in new york city
last year there were approximately
an uncompressed CSVs so clearly I'm not
gonna be able to explore all of that on
my machine there are some sampling
techniques to try and help you down
sample you know you can do a random
Gaussian selection of your data in order
to get a smaller subset to work with i
believe tony tran is giving a
presentation on that tomorrow you want
to see more about that but for this
purpose I've just selected one of the
months februari and I've done a few
different plots to try and demonstrate
how you can interpret data in a
visualization so I'm loading up a here
well as Matt plot live with some Seaborn
defaults and for the first pass I'm just
importing the first 10,000 rows which is
you know large enough at least get an
understanding of the visualization but
all enough to be manageable on my laptop
so this is our our data frame we've got
the medallion a hack license which are
unique to each taxi vendor IDs rate
codes which I wasn't familiar with
coming from Austin but you know they're
one through five depending on the
starting and ending estimations up and
drop off day times passenger counts trip
time in seconds and distance and you get
pick up longitude latitude drop off
longitude latitude so Edward Tufte in
his I think one of his more infamous for
Marx said that eighty seventy to eighty
percent of graphical representations are
scatter plots and that maybe you know
high or low depending on your
understanding but it's it's pretty true
generally you want to look at the end
race and a relationship between two
variables and so x and y-axes provide a
great intuitive way for most of us to
visualize that so this is on the x axis
we have got the trip time in seconds and
all the y axis the trip distance so
literally this is the first thing i did
i decided to choose two columns take a
look at them visualize it with scatter
plot and the first thing you understand
is there are a lot of outliers you can't
see them very much on this low contrast
screen but
there are definitely some trips that
went on for what 3540 miles and took
7,000 8,000 seconds we can iterate
quickly bring that down to minutes so
you can see some trips actually took
over an hour or over like 80 minutes if
you're doing a machine learning
algorithm on the status set you're not
going to want to include some of these
outliers as you know very highly
important if you so you always have you
know two choices you can either exclude
them for the data set entirely which
generally isn't a good thing to do but
for exploratory data analysis you're not
even there yet you might want to just
zoom in or select a certain area here
though we have the cardinal sin of big
data which is over plotting how many of
you guys ever hit over plotting when
you're trying to yeah hit a large data
set you've definitely found that in in
some corner generally where your x and y
are minimal you have to make points that
can be adequately plotted so we have
alpha constraints and alpha is a you
have to understand this is an HTML
element you only have ranges from 0 to
255 so an alpha of 0.2 here which I've
specified basically says that if you
have 5 acting the same ER you've already
hit over plotting again so in order to
avoid this you have to go into a
different regime which is called
abstract rendering there's going to be
an entire talk on that cold abstract
grant sorry you an entire section on
that and the bouquet talk tomorrow but
zooming and panning I know they seem
really simple things but coming into
this data set if you zoom in on this
corner what do you start to see
automatically right exactly you've got
discretization of trip time in minutes
and this is something that may not be
immediately apparent to you if you're
just scanning through your data but when
you visualize it it pops out its
immediate as visceral so if you wanted
to get a slightly better representation
of this you might want to you know
jitter your data points which creates a
small offset either in the X or Y
direction to try and keep them from
hitting the same areas so what I'm doing
here now is in just pandas selection
creating the trip time I'm getting all
the all the trips that lasts less than
60 minutes just setting a bound same
with trip distance I'm looking for trips
that are less than four miles and now
this is a seaborne joint plot it uses a
hex bidding technique in order to
generate the hex plot and this is
advantageous over scatter plots or
regular heat maps that are on a
rectangular grid because hex plots have
six angles right so you've got a better
chance of capturing a point in a
particular hex bin than you would in a
rectangular grid this provides also a a
histogram view on the top and right bar
where you can clearly see some of this
discretization effects in the
empty columns so how Center cows yeah
you can't exactly do a scatter plot of
passing this is plotting the trip
distance against the passenger count if
I wanted to see how far our most people
going if you know they're in a car
versus if they've got a couple friends
in tow but you have a violin plot for
example which has a it's it's a
combination of a box plot in a kernel
density estimation so this doesn't make
sense for this kind of data you don't
use a violent flawed if you got discrete
units right so you would throw it into
Seaborn and create a histogram you can
see that most trips are taken with just
one passenger and then it tails off for
two to six passengers well a trip time
in seconds this is where violent plot
would actually be useful you want to see
approximately the distribution of trip
length are people taking shorter trip so
they taking longer trips are most trips
within a certain range and because this
violent plot also overlays a box plot
you can see that the average trip length
is you know approximately 600 seconds
and then you also get the interquartile
ranges and a proper kernel of the entire
range but this makes more sense it
actually makes more sense to put time as
a linear scale on the x-axis how many
times have you seen a scatter plot where
time is on the y-axis for example right
you don't generally see evolution of a
model as it goes up or down you see it
as it goes left or right and weak or be
naturally as humans you know we think
about figures as left and right for time
going backward or forward there's always
a a better orientation general and
that's something that emerges once you
start to consider the grammar of
graphics you start to understand that we
shouldn't be just shoving our data into
statistical plots we should be trying to
look at our
in the broadest way fast broadest
fashion imaginable first and then
iteratively goose or select properties
of the plot which interests us or which
will then you know yields more
information and part of that is also you
know the figure aesthetic choosing
whether you're going left to right for
time or up or down okay so this is a
plot of oh sorry so what I'm doing here
actually is loading the entire data set
so you know I initially accepted to the
first 10,000 rows now I'm loading the
entire thing setting the index to the
pickup date I'm so then I can sort by
the index day and then plot it as a bar
chart so this is basically going to show
me the number of trips taken per day
through februari by the taxis and
actually I think this is going to take
another 10 seconds or so so these are
problems you have you know these are
hashtag big data problems along the
lines of first world problems there are
a lot of ways to try and interact with
data out of core that are perhaps not as
intuitive for Python libraries so if
you're at all interested in out of core
problems you know you have data sets
that don't fit in memory or you don't
even have two columns that could fit in
memory then definitely check out the
blaze talk tomorrow which is going to be
delivered by Matthew Rockland highly
recommended so what's the what's the
first pattern you can detect you know
for this kind of data you see that for
the most part it is relatively
relatively normalized you have
approximately 500,000 trips per day by
these taxis and you can also see what
our weekly patterns this is the thing
that emerges you know when you bring
other understanding to the table that on
weekends you have a peek trip times you
know you have bar plots that extend
higher than others but when you're doing
the exploratory data analysis and you
don't have that model in mind it's
actually incredibly freeing
because at that point you are literally
playing with the data your conception of
you know the data set is what you bring
from external information like in this
case I know these are taxi trips I know
they have you know these pickup and
dropoff longitudes and that most taxi
trips don't go 40 miles you know most
taxi trips don't have a tip that ranges
in the nine hundred percent range we're
clearly not like bottles that use those
you know outliers as statistically
significant points and the other hand
when you have the models and you're
trying to confirm it against the data at
that point it's almost like you're
taking a test it you've basically
decided yes this is the approach and the
information that we have and this is how
we're going to try and fit the data into
our understand so here are tips for
normal people for the entire data set
right again it's more or less what
you've seen before the subsample
actually does a pretty good job because
taxi trips are randomly distributed
right you don't expect that on the first
of every versus the fifteenth of
februari there's going to be a much
appreciable difference
okay yeah so so what one frustrating
thing about this is that data sets are
messy right and we've hear this all the
time we have data sets are messy and in
order to clean it up that is also part
of the exploratory analysis if you're if
you're doing one thing right it should
be cleaning your data set and
visualizing it as you go if you're
cleaning and visualizing you literally
see what you're managing to take out of
the way coming back up here if you yeah
if you decided to clean the status set
for appropriate statistical analysis
you're not doing any modeling you just
want to show somebody right you're not
going to show them this plot this plot
isn't as meaningful as this one this
plot is more meaningful because it's
given well it's not actually
ok
that and then that oh and this oh that's
going to break my laptop okay sorry okay
so one limitation of okay right now is
the fact that you can't plot 10 billion
points that's that's okay well we're
getting there our goal our goal is still
higher but one thing I was interested in
is why so many people tipped 0 this did
not accord with my intuition because at
the very least if you're you know in a
taxi and you've got a fifty percent tip
option if you swipe your card you you
could hit that right why is it that most
people go for no tip and so so yet a
hypothesis a your taxi driver was an
[ __ ] and you really wanted to avoid
you know giving him any indication that
he did a good job or that there's you
know some other hidden variable at play
and that's what a lot of data analysis
actually is is determining what that
quote unquote hidden variable is right
it's not actually present if you're
looking at the data set on as an
overview but very data analysis you'll
find so much as up
and type thing in to show up and you
know cleaning your data sub 0 see ash
but if you select on fair tip amount to
0 and you do the same group i do the
same plot you can error you get two
errors
ok
yeah okay see this thing
sorry it's quiet oh oh okay I'll strip
guys else trip to the l strip ok
okay we're going thank you so yeah this
is your explanation you could you
clearly see that for some reason cards
are completely under reported for tips
compared to cash in fact it's to the
point where you have some statistically
significant at least you want to
investigate a little bit further and see
why it is specifically that those cards
are giving tips you know you can analyze
those on other other vectors you can see
trip time trip distance you know where
they're going farther a shorter was it
some reason that you know maybe they
were in a hurry and they really need to
get out and didn't give time for a tip
oh oh okay yes
right because cards don't report right
cards any two percentage that's entered
they also have the same same amount
docked from for the credit card
processing fees that
RS right you can't just collect it same
sketch okay so that's the explanation
here we all know what's going on or at
least you all know for sure what's going
on exploratory data analysis
fantastic plotting libraries okay it's
fantastic
interesting stuff with length brushing
and panning and stuff
here self if you're cleaning a set
you're using pandas visualizes you go
take a look at your data see what
accords with your intuition and what
doesn't and do make judgment calls thank
you